on September 13th a woman named Masa
amini was detained by Iran's morality
police for improperly wearing her hijab
she was loaded into a van where she was
reportedly beaten and then transferred
to a Detention Center where she
collapsed and fell into a coma three
days later she died at the hospital and
protests broke out as a result Iran shut
down the country's internet but hundreds
of social media posts of people
protesting her death have surfaced over
the last three months including videos
of women defiantly cutting their hair
the symbol of beauty the regime once
hidden under the hijab
thank you
[Applause]
the so-called morality police patrol the
streets to enforce the regime's strict
dress code they mostly target women and
how they wear the hijab and will either
find them or arrest them and take them
to detention centers they are one part
of the repressive State apparatus that
wields power over Iranians but far from
the only one
that the protests we can see different
armed groups violently suppressing the
protests
understanding who they might be tells us
a lot about the power structure Iranians
are fighting to change
[Music]
in the 1970s Iran was a secular monarchy
that operated as a dictatorship under
the Shah Iranians lacked political
freedoms but enjoyed social ones they
also experienced economic growth that
rapidly transformed Iran from a
traditional conservative Society to an
industrial modernized one soon economic
frustrations and political repression
sparked uprisings calling for new
Islamic rule they went on for a year but
the regime remained in place until a
crucial Turning Point the Army declared
neutrality it was then that the monarchy
collapsed and gave way to the Islamic
Republic that rules today but that
neutrality that allowed the regime to
come to power was also one of its
biggest weaknesses the revolutionaries
did not trust the Army which was
supposed to be loyal to the Shah but
stabbed them in the back the best
strategy was to hedge their bets by
creating a branch of armed forces that
they could trust much more than the Army
under the Supreme Leader's rule the
regime kept the old Army but created a
separate military group called the
Islamic revolutionary guard Corps this
group was crucial in the long War Iran
fought against Iraq the Revolutionary
guard played an important role in trying
to push back the Iraqi Army and after
that they managed to turn that political
Capital into economic influence and
political power as their importance grew
so did their domestic security rule
which sometimes meant fighting against
the people
videos verified by Human Rights Watch
show Armed Forces beating protesters
using assault weapons and men dressed in
black riding motorcycles and firing guns
into crowds these men dressed in black
fit the description of the besiege a
paramilitary volunteer militia under the
irgc that's fiercely loyal to the
Supreme Leader primarily it was a force
that was created in order to do social
control in September Amnesty
International obtained documents showing
the Armed Forces instructed their chain
of command to severely confront
protesters
and a local Commander ordering Security
Forces to confront mercilessly while
going as far as causing deaths as a
result human rights groups say at least
18 000 protesters have been arrested and
at least 250 have been killed including
more than 60 children
and now Iran has started carrying out
executions
[Applause]
the reason so many protesters are out on
the streets is that Iran's power
structure doesn't give them any
alternatives just like the armed forces
are a pillar of the Islamic Republic
there are several others supporting the
country's power structure these are just
a few of them and while some should be
independent they aren't this includes
Iran's legislative branch because while
these government bodies are technically
elected they are controlled by the
regime's appointed Guardian Council that
means the regime can disqualify
candidates and reject laws that go
through Parliament overriding the will
of the people the unelected institutions
have continuously stymied and sabotage
those reforms and that has created a
sense of despondency within the society
so in the last 20 years Iranians have
taken to the streets at an increasing
rate against electoral fraud government
corruption economic hardship and again
today
soon after amini's death a video of her
funeral went viral women took off their
hijabs and the crowd started chanting
a chance have take hold all over the
country
[Applause]
in the past 10-15 years in Iran that
they often start with much more narrower
objectives or demands but this time
around almost from the get-go the zero
to 100 happened overnight and
immediately there were calls for regime
change but the system they are trying to
change was built to suppress dissent and
protect power at the top the idea of
having multiple power centers and
parallel institutions is for the regime
to hedge its pets none of these
individual elements can on their own
pose a threat to the clinical power
making it nearly impossible to topple
such a multi-layered decentralized power
structure the fact that there is now no
longer any hopes in the possibility of
reforming the system from within it has
created the situation in which the
younger generation of Iranians
increasingly believe that they have
nothing to lose most of the protesters
are young Iranians who were born After
the Revolution and inherited a system
they didn't ask for despite the
censorship young Iranians have cut the
world's attention schoolgirls are
filming themselves replacing portraits
of the supreme leader with the words
woman life Freedom setting their hijabs
on fire and chasing pro-regime Educators
out of their schools the current
situation is the product of the Islamic
Republic's failures over the years the
Islamic Republic failed to create a
country in which the youth could see a
future for themselves it's really as
simple as that
foreign
[Music]